Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is my
house of the dragon video for the alternate
endings the deleted scenes that they just revealed
after the season finale so most of this stuff is
from the finale but some of the deleted scenes the
alternate takes are from earlier episodes because
it was so much story they were covering George RR
Martin also said that he expects even more deleted
scenes to be on the Blu-ray when they release
that as well so when we get those I'll do another
deleted scenes video for anything new that they
haven't revealed yet deleted scenes in many of the
episodes so we could add back to deleted scenes
and that's something that they frequently like
to do if you're new to the channel I'll be doing
videos for House of the Dragon season 2 during
the break until it starts be sure to subscribe to
get everything and when the Blu-ray does come out
later this year I'll do some special giveaways for
it I believe that's happening in December careful
for spoilers for season one if you haven't seen
it yet but there were hours and hours of deleted
scenes alternate takes ton of stuff Hit The
Cutting Room floor but one of the biggest things
was the actual ending of the finale The House
of the Dragon episode 10 ending we saw ended
with lucerys versus aemond vhagar killing air acts
against Aemond's wishes Iraq's attacking vhagar to
begin with against lucerys' wishes turns out they
don't actually control the dragons as much as they
thought they did viserys had a big speech about
that at the beginning of episode 1. Lucerys dies
accidentally as collateral damage in the attack
and it was really Dragon vs dragon fight a true
Dance of the dragons and then rhaenyra learning
about it after the fact decided to declare war
on the greens after all whereas before she'd imply
that she was going to accept the terms and attempt
to avert war even though they were always going
to have the war the showrunner Ryan Condall said
that there had been a few different versions of
the actual ending the only thing that was always
going to be the same in all the different versions
was lucerys dying like his death was always going
to happen in the season finale at some point and
season 2 was always going to begin with the actual
dance of the dragons their first version of the
ending like the first alternate version was meant
to be more like the ending of episode 9 where
they end the season with alicent and the greens
crowning aegon II stealing the Iron Throne is
his big twist then rhaenyra learns about it and
declares war on them as we saw the just use
that moment for the ending of episode 9 and
separated the alicent and the rhaenyra stories
into completely different episodes like episode
9 was called the green Council it was more from
alicent's perspective episode 10 was called The
Black Queen it was more from rhaenyra perspective
things which I think was a smarter move on their
part like they were already rushing through so
much story already the other alternate ending was
more of a minor change and it was aemond killing
lucerys then inside Dragonstone during rhaenyra's
black council meeting around the painted table
while they're discussing what they're gonna
do next Daemon was going to have a much bigger
scene with her where he walks in starts telling
her about what happened to lucerys and they would
have had an actual conversation with a much more
drawn out reaction from renera like you would
have actually heard him speaking to her about
it and then her crying out in the final version
it's completely silent you don't hear what he's
actually saying to her you just see their backs
turn to the fireplace with her physical reaction
which they said was actually totally improvised by
Matt Smith on the day like Matt Smith came in on
the day that they were filming this scene called
an audible and suggested that instead of having
this huge Converse station about what was going
on and being more deliberate about rhaenyra's next
actions it ended up being an amazing scene in the
final version it tells you everything you need to
know about where season two begins no dialogue
needed talking about the biggest deleted scenes
from earlier episodes they ended episode 5 with
branera marrying laner velaryon and Laena let
Daemon know that she was interested in marrying
him now that he was available she also didn't
seem very sad about the death of his first wife
and then they just completely skip over all of
Daemon and Laena's story after that in favor of
the epic time Jump at the beginning of episode 6
where everyone's first batch of kids are huge
it was meant to be about a 10-year time Jump
obviously there was a ton of stuff that they
skipped over for all the different story lines
but just for the Daemon and laena's storyline by
itself the biggest missing parts that they got rid
of was the story of how Daemon was actually able
to marry laena because it was a whole bunch of
stabbing and killing that Daemon had to do before
that could take place when laena expresses her
interest in Daemon and Daemon is amenable to it
like okay that sounds like a good idea let's do
that at that time laena was already betrothed to
the son of the Sea Lord of braavos so Daemon's way
of fixing this wound up being very similar to
the way that rhaenyra helped lanor get out of
their marriage later in episode 7. like you could
see with her taking stuff from some storylines
and giving the moments to other storylines so
after rhaenyra's wedding was over Daemon came
to driftmark and corlys velaryon was amenable
to a match between Daemon and his daughter like
he wanted to get his family as connected to the
Iron Throne as possible as connected to the royal
family as possible and what had happened over in
braavos is that the Sea;ord that he had made this
marriage pact with for his son and his daughter
had died and the Sealord's son had taken over and
squandered all of his money so corlys didn't care
about braavos anymore but he couldn't break the
marriage pack without good cause so Daemon went
full Rogue Prince like he pulled very familiar
move where he comes to braavos and he goads the
sea Lord's son into a fight attacking him and
use it as an excuse to kill him his head thus
ending laena's betrothal allowing them to get
married is also kind of similar to the way that
he dealt with his first marriage like oh we'll
just kill our problems away how do we get you
out of this betrothal why don't we just kill
the person you're betrothed to problem solved
like I said in a very Daemon kind of way so I
think that they decided to get rid of that moment
with Daemon and laena because it was so similar to
The Twist they were using for Lenor later on and
because they wanted such an epic jarring time Jump
to so much later in the timeline like that let's
just kind of hand wave over all this history here
and because of that there's also this other huge
deleted scene from Daemon laena's storyline where
laena claims vhagar when she was much much younger
so here's the thing with that too there are also
a couple minor book changes that they had with
alicent and rhaenyra's character and some of the
younger characters as well they did the same thing
during the original Game of Thrones series where
they changed the ages of some of the characters
in the books originally laena claimed vhagar in
105 AC that's the same year that viserys's first
wife aemma arryn died in childbirth and that was
the end of episode 1 on the series but when we
get to episode 2 and we meet laena velaryon she's
like a very very young child clearly a long ways
off from claiming vhagar they did the same thing
with rhaenyra and alicent on the show on the show
alicent is way older than ranera and she's in her
late 20s when she gets remarried to viserys on
the show they made it seem like alicent was like
14-15 when she got married to viserys but laena
claimed vhagar when she was about 13 years old and
if you're going by the show's timeline that would
have been some time between the events of episode
4 and episode 5. like when she shows up in episode
5 to renira's wedding and she starts talking to
Daemon she's a couple years older she's old enough
to actually start having children and she's been
writing vhagar for a little while already the
main reason why they said they didn't include her
writing Veigar in the final episodes was because
they wanted Aemond to claiming vhagar at the end
of episode 7 just a few episodes right after that
to feel like a much bigger deal kind of the same
reason why they didn't include ladies stoneheart
on the Game of Thrones series because like right
after that would have happened they would have had
the big Jon Snow Resurrection moment and catelyn's
Stark coming back as lady stoneheart would have
telegraphed that too much like amid was always
going to be a much bigger character on the show
in general to them through all the seasons so
they wanted to focus more on setting his character
up which is another side effect of them brushing
through the story so fast there are also a
bunch of deleted scenes from much earlier on too
especially alicent and viserys's marriage as well
there was a huge time Jump between episode 2 and
episode 3 and at the beginning of the cut that we
actually saw the series had already been married
to alicent for a couple of years and her first son
with him aegon II is having his second birthday
so like a lot of time has gone by in this first
deleted scene renera meets alicent right after
the engagement is announced before the wedding
ceremony in the godswood here they keep using this
as a big location in the episodes keep going back
here mythologically it's also one of the biggest
connections that they have to the Game of Thrones
series in the weirwood trees the three-eyed Raven
the children of the forest the night King the
white walkers the long night and the scene would
have had ranera yelling at alicent about how much
much of a betrayal it felt like like you kind of
get that moment after the engagement is announced
but you don't actually get a scene between the two
of them until well after her first child has been
born they were meant to be best friends before
that if this wasn't clear like the actresses also
said that they had been playing their relationship
as if they were also kind of secretly in love like
the connection had a romantic component to it but
it wasn't as overtly sexual as you would normally
think for a show like Game of Thrones given what
we just saw happen in episode 4. given all that
sister wiping in Twin sets we see happening all
over the place both of the actresses said that
that wasn't on the page like their romantic
relationship before things get really awkward with
the events of the show it was just something that
they chose to do on their own like they made it
feel like more of a romantic connection between
the two of them and they would have made it clear
during this deleted scene that alicent didn't want
to marry her father she was just kind of forced to
do it but as you see in later episodes alicent as
a character just feels like she needs to follow
the rules do whatever everyone tells her to do
so she does whatever her father says to to do
even if she doesn't really want to do it which
is part of the reason why she gets so pissed off
at renera when she finds out about what she's been
up to in flea bottom with Daemon Targaryen so
if it wasn't clear alicent didn't actually want
to get married to her father she liked the
attention that she was getting with the King
like she thought that she was special because the
attention like oh someone's paying attention to me
this is great like she wasn't trying to betray
her friend renera the second deleted scene was
the actual marriage ceremony of alicent Hightower
and viserys Targaryen a little while later in the
timeline they actually filmed the wedding this
is what alicent's wedding dress would have looked
like it's a very Targaryen themed dress done in
white and red instead of black and red all the
costumes on house the dragon and Game of Thrones
are fantastic they must have spent so much money
filming this scene to cut it we haven't seen many
actual weddings in the Game of Thrones Universe
they've all gone terribly the Red Wedding the
purple wedding sansa's Force wedding to Ramsay
Bolton I'm assuming that it's common for Highborn
ladies in Westeros to wear white to weddings
though enduring the larger wedding scene they
actually filmed rhaenyra helping Alice doesn't
get dressed in her gown in their ritual like the
dressing was meant to be a parallel for alicent
helping rhaenyra do the same thing getting dressed
when she was preparing to be named the air earlier
in the series and have all the Lords of the realm
swear fealty to her so it was meant to be like
this very personal moment with them together right
before alicent got married to her father and it
would have shown how close they were despite what
had just happened between the two of them with the
Betrayal and her getting engaged to her father the
next deleted scene was after alicent and viserys'
wedding with him learning that she was going to
give birth to a son aegon II and it was meant
to be a happy scene like it was him celebrating
that he'd have a son that would survive the birth
he'd had two male children with Aemma Arryn his
first wife were near his mother but neither one
of them survived long after birth mostly the
blame for that lies on the Targaryen practice
of marrying so closely in the family for so long
the Sears and Daemon's parents were brother and
sister and viserys and his first wife Aemma were
first cousins Aemma was the daughter of one of
jaehaerys' many many children the next deleted
scene was going to be be a larger introduction
for laenor velaryon and his lover Joffrey lonmouth
the person in the episode 5 trailer that you see
Criston Cole just laying it into during The
Wedding Banquet being named Joffrey at a royal
wedding like this just doesn't seem like a good
idea in the Game of Thrones Universe everybody
having Joffrey flashbacks to Game of Thrones in
the purple wedding I think the idea here was that
they were going to do a better job of setting up
laner before rhaenyra meets him during viserys
discussions with Corlys velaryon arranging their
marriage then after the fact they also clarified
what was really going on with Daemon when he
was with renera in flea bottom and they were
getting it on Matt Smith explained during this
scene he was actually trying to get back at his
brother like purposefully trying to rile things
up causing a little bit of chaos messing around
with runera and the reason why he stopped because
he couldn't metaphorically get it up so to speak
is because when they started to get hot and heavy
she actually doubled down on it got into it and
that freaked him out a little bit and he suddenly
realized how crazy what they were doing was like
okay maybe I've gone a little too far this time
and then pumps the break and takes off some of the
other smaller deleted scenes from later episodes
also include more stuff with the actual dinner
scene like viserys's Last Supper during that
part of the episode alicent had a scene with
Criston Cole where she gets really pissed off
at him in stark contrast to what we've seen in
their relationship in the final episodes before
and if you notice in this dinner scene you look
around you don't see Criston Cole anywhere near
alicent where usually you'd expect him to follow
her around most places like a puppy he's been her
personal kingsguard on alicent detail so to speak
ever since the time jump Olivia Cooke revealed
that they had this funny scene where alicent
gets super pissed off at him and basically tells
him to piss off and he goes off in this funny way
with his tail between his legs so to speak like
a dog who's just been disciplined by their owner
which is why you don't see him when the kids start
to throw down and aim into jaserus almost get into
a fight until Daemon steps in between them if
there are any other alternate endings or deleted
scenes that I didn't talk about in this video
that you noticed just write them Below in the
comments and I'll try to address them in future
videos like I said when the Blu-ray comes out
we'll probably learn about even more deleted
scenes so I'll do a lot more video and also
be posting house the dragon season 2 videos on a
regular basis so post all your big questions your
special requests for all those bonus videos in
the comments below but everyone click here for my
house of the Dragon season 2 video and click here
for my Full House of the Dragon episode 10 finale
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!